hillwood welcome to this video playing
Grand Master Julian hodgson is he
playing the Trump he is yeah its
trademark opening yeah this I think is
just a good line for black not like
you're better but I think black is fine
Bishop the successor has the key idea
you for then be five leads to an
immensely unclear position yeah this is
what I have recommended in my benko
gambit based anti-d for repertoire and
I'm happy with this however the kind of
murky position is of course right up
Hodgson's allahís am always was
extremely strong in in a tricky and hard
to understand positions okay so how am I
going to play him Bishop d7 maybe yeah
okay he might take take five then the
compensation for that is probably not
one hundred percent obvious okay I go
before
also shouldn't be that bad so we should
be several try to take on the 35
Aoife at night f5 always should be
should be fine interesting interesting
so and how is he handling this here try
to annoy me on the dark square at night
a 62 c 5 would be good and also 'if I've
potentially e5 Knight a six that's very
weird the bishop on b7
I need to reorganize a little bit here
especially Bishop Vaughn be seven and 96
they have to have to be a place to
differently this is extremely slow I
hope that works
93 d 6 I know before his hanging oh come
on that's that's annoying the position
was kind of okay right this is really
not what I wanted and he can take on
before I shall him ah that was
completely unnecessary yeah in 7s
hanging that that's really really bad I
really think that this position is
actually pretty bad for white soul
openings pretty awful i think but anyway
i couldn't couldn't prove it
I know Wes bishop is not good but ask my
bishop on c8 it's also pretty terrible
I mean I don't actually think that what
the white set up is totally terrible as
I said it's just that i find it entirely
anesthetic it's just a bit of a matter
of taste maybe if white takes look on
the second must be a draw actually I
hope she wants to go root g one
hmm that's not good check yeah cannot
really do much em check
I get the deep hole it would be so kind
of interesting but looks difficult to do
check I cannot go before even as I
wanted so stupid jack is them somewhat
active yeah I don't know if I'm here
this probably input check draw a herd of
course game drive yeah I guess 20
seconds so that's it and it's wrong that
that's the other thing hmm yeah that's
it i dislike the wide opening completely
so i really don't like that i didn't get
more out of this so you should be 7 to
stand and smooth yeah this is the more
this is a sharper move but i couldn't
quite figure this one out but it's ok i
just saw that lets say he takes it but i
have 94 and not okay i didn't see that
the night is also checking see two yeah
then we should be seven is of course
stronger because before i started move
i'd like to play so the engine gives
this an f5 some something like that yeah
why it is not so well developed and has
problems on the darks
where's yeah that would have been would
have been a bit better get here yeah
maybe I don't have to play five yeah
that's possible the computer wants to do
this and this is very happy about my
position yeah it's true actually I don't
have to play five here Jim the way it
was played I even overlooked that I'm
losing the losing this then here I
should definitely reduce the game check
whoops check check yeah he should win
somehow if I've the engine probably yes
I mean white has two connected pan so
that should be a win somehow chant okay
he didn't have that much time check
check then there was this possibility
and this is something I have to I have
to play computer wants to do this
keeping the rooks on this is a good idea
after the rook trade check it's just the
wrong okay that was a tough fight
against Hudson I really don't fare well
against them minus one was the score ok
guys thanks for watching